It's time for Yearbook Oh Nos.
Yearbook Oh Nos.
Yearbooks were clearly invented
by some sadistic bastard
who thought it was a great idea
to have photo evidence
of the most awkward years
of your life!
If you're lucky, you get tagged
with a superlative like
Most Likely to Steal Yo' Girl,
like...
(laughter)
(cheering and applause)
Look at...
look at that.
Just take the bowl off
and then just eat spaghetti out
of it right after.
I was wearing big dorky glasses
before it was still not cool!
So, comedians, I'm gonna show
you some truly bad selections
from BadYearbookPhotos.com,
and I want you to tell me
what superlative they earned
in school.
First up, this lounging lad.
Colton.
Most Likely to Crap Himself
at a Chuck E. Cheese.
"No, not in the ball pit!"
Uh, points, points.
Next up,
this young daughter of a gun.
Yes, Burnie.
Most Likely to Secede.
Points.
Yep. Yeah.
Next up, this shocking fellow.
-Oh...
-Burnie.
Most Likely to be Launched
into a Galaxy by NASA.
Yes, points.
Points.
Mm-hmm.
Next up, this meat body. Yeah.
Colton.
Most Likely to Get His Head
Stuck in a Doorway.
-Points.
-He got a big head.
The (bleep) is he looking at?!
Next up,
this gap-toothed student.
Gavin.
(chuckles)
First Person to Floss
with a Bungee Cord.
Points.
By the way, that's, uh,
our-our good friend
on @midnight, Alison Agosti.
Thank you for letting us use
your picture, Alison!
-It's still... it's still
way better than mine. -Yeah.
Next up, this jive jack.
Burnie.
Most Likely to be Arrested
for Possession of Oregano.
Points.
Yep.
Finally, this relaxed rocker.
Uh, yes, Gavin.
Most Likely to (bleep) Up
Machete Juggling.
Points.